welcome to europe's latest headache a
fault line where the european union ends
and a sliver of russia begins
here to the southwest of lithuania is
kaliningrad it's a russian legacy of the
second world war an exclave about the
size of northern ireland
for decades it's been supplied by cargo
running through lithuania but now
sanctions have been imposed on things
like building materials and coal
and these trains are arriving half empty
russia has threatened reprisals and
lithuania's government is nervous
there are discussions with the western
allies about a permanent nato brigade in
lithuania this situation shows that we
really need to have additional
capabilities in lithuania
the unanswered question lingers just
what is russia threatening standing here
you can see why lithuania is so nervous
russia has stationed short and
long-range missiles and built a mighty
military base right on the border of the
european union
not everyone is anxious though virgilius
and thomas grew up here they talk of
kaliningrad as a neighbour
we have friends in there in russia there
are normal peoples i think
and they are not so dangerous you know
but as you move further away opinions
harden
arena's parents brought her from russia
to lithuania when she was just a child
she says she grieves for her home
country and worries that russia might
now attack
i am afraid i feel angry because the war
has all people here in the vienna it's
normal thinking what's happening in
ukraine right now so just thinking
always we remember always about this
in moscow broadcasters call this all a
blockade
russia's media has been increasingly
controlled since the war in ukraine
began something else lithuania says it's
trying to address
so here's the overnight passenger train
from moscow pulling across the
lithuanian border
it stops for customs checks
once passengers would have got out to
stretch their legs now they all stay on
board
it is unclear how much they know about
the war
along this platform there are huge
posters showing graphic images accusing
russia of genocide
behind the curtains of the train
passengers are invited to use free wi-fi
but first they have to scroll through
more photos from the war
the train sets off slowly towards
kaliningrad this is a story about
sanctions and borders but it's shaped by
conflict and a fracturing continent
adam parsons sky news lithuania